database profiling is critical for
finding bottlenecks or other issues that
might be degrading the user experience
in this episode we're going to look at
the built in firebase profiler tool
which will give us a breakdown of the
memory and speed performance of our
database this tutorial is done in the
context of an angular application but in
just as easily be applied to the
firebase JavaScript SDK if you're just
getting started with firebase you'll
need to install the firebase tools
command-line interface and then
initialize your project by running in
firebase and knit to demonstrate this
feature we're going to read and write a
bunch of weather data in the firebase
database which I've acquired here from
the dark sky API so I went ahead and
parsed this JSON into JavaScript and
then I'm importing it in an angular
component here when we save the data to
firebase it's going to look like this a
big object with its own nested objects
and arrays not something you would
consider optimize for efficiency in a no
sequel database then back in the angular
component I'm going to create an
observable stopwatch which will help us
determine the actual latency the user
sees on the front-end so we can start
the stopwatch as soon as we make a
request and then as soon as firebase
returns us an actual object we'll stop
the stopwatch and then all display that
number in milliseconds on the front end
we can do this in rxjs by creating an
observable interval that ticks every one
millisecond and to finish the stopwatch
we just call unsubscribe on it then
going down into the angular component we
can just create a new instance of the
stopwatch and then inject the angular
fired database and the constructor then
the first thing we'll profile is the
write speed to the real-time database
first I'll quickly show you the plain
firebase SDK code basically we just make
a reference to the database and then
push new objects to it then back in
angular we'll do the same thing but
using that angular fire to wrapper and I
want to push 20 objects to the database
so I use a for loop here and then for
each iteration du DB push that's going
to return a promise so once we get to
the very last iteration we will wait for
the promise to resolve and at that point
we'll stop the stopwatch now to run the
firebase profiler tool all we have to do
is bring up the command line and then
run firebase database colon
profile this command will record
everything that's happening in the
database until we actually tell it to
stop now we can go into our angular app
and then run the write method and that's
gonna put 20 different items in the
database and we can see we had 119
milliseconds of latency on the front-end
then we can go back to the command line
and click enter and then we get the
report back from firebase there's a
bunch of different stuff to look at here
but for this operation we want to look
at the right speed so that'll give us
the number of operations that occurred
at this node and the average speed and
will tell us whether or not permission
was denied for that operation we can
also get feedback on memory usage and we
can see each operation here require 29.8
7 kilobytes you can see these figures
for both the uploaded and downloaded
memory ok so now that we have some data
in the database we're gonna start
looking at profiles for reading data the
first thing we're gonna do is read data
as a list and just to show you the
regular firebase code here we just have
a reference and then we'll get the
snapshot of that reference then an
angular we start the stopwatch and then
we make a query for a firebase list then
I add some query parameters here to sort
the elements by the child property of
latitude at this point we don't have an
index built for latitudes so this is
going to be a very efficient inefficient
query but in the next step I'll show you
how to set that up and firebase and
lastly we subscribe to the observable
and then stop the stopwatch once it
emits some data so we'll start a new
profile and then once we run this query
we get a warning from firebase that we
don't have an index on the latitude
property so we can optimize performance
by going into the firebase database
rules and then just adding index on with
the property that we want to index and
firebase will automatically create an
index to optimize sorting by that
property if we rerun the query we get a
slight increase in performance and we no
longer see the warning but this will be
a huge increase in performance as your
list gets bigger the profiler tool will
also warn us if we're making any
unindexed queries so that's another nice
feature of the profiler the next
performance topic we're going to look at
is what happens when you make multiple
queries at the same time intuitively you
might think making a whole bunch of
queries at the same time
gonna be really slow and inefficient but
in reality firebase handles everything
in a non-blocking manner so we can send
multiple requests and it can actually
still be really fast so here I have 20
push keys from the database as an array
and we're going to make a separate
request for each one of these push keys
then I'm going to console.log the
request and the response in different
colors just to show you how firebase
actually handles these requests and then
like before we'll stop the stopwatch
once we get the last item back from
firebase so if we run this code in the
angular app notice we get 20 requests
sent and then we get a batch of 20
responses back all at the same time so
you can break your request into multiple
smaller requests and you won't have any
loss in performance generally speaking
this time I added a hundred millisecond
delay between each request and you can
see we get the responses back in
different sized batches depending on
when they're actually ready in firebase
so the bottom line here is that you can
send multiple simultaneous requests to
firebase without sacrificing much in
terms of performance that's it for
firebase database profiling if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to get
involved with the channel consider
joining our slack team or becoming a pro
member at angular firebase comm thanks
for watching and I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]